your house as a fine little house Jack
are you allowed to speak along the way I
was thinking there might be rules let me
put it this way way if you make it all
the way without uttering a word but do
carry on merrily just don't believe
you're going to tell me something I
haven't heard before
[Music]
so I was maybe a mistake what was my
mistake me getting in this car with you
you might as well be a serial killer
sorry but you do kind of look like one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some people claim that the atrocities we
commit in our fiction are those inner
desires which we cannot commit in our
controlled civilization so they are
expressed instead through our art I
don't agree
I believe heaven in hell are one in the
same the soul belongs to heaven and the
body to hell
[Music]
when I think about all the things I've
done in my life
without in any way resulting in
punishment
you
[Music]
the old cathedrals often have sublime
artworks hidden away in the darkest
corners for only God to see the same
goes for murder
[Music]
you